>>Oli: Today in the next hour or so,
year nine will be taking part
in their political ignite.
This is the end of a term's
worth of research on key topics
around the London mayoral election,
and they're ready to debate each other
to make sure they've got
the winning argument.
>>Because of all the Oracy
that's happening in lessons,
we have seen students showing an
oral dexterity beyond their years.
We've seen them able to be
thrown into different situations,
to judge the audience, to
understand how to present themselves
so it both raises standards and
prepares them for the future.
>>Students: [applause]
>>Coach: If I have to sum up School 21,
it's giving young people the
voice they might not be able
to find for themselves.
It gives them the power to realize that
who they are and who they want to be
in their voice is the very thing
that's gonna make them successful.
>>Rummana: Talk is my number one thing
I'm going to be using in my life.
All of us here talk and
everyone's voice matters.
>>Oli: Oracy is the ability
to speak fluently
and we believe the Oracy speaking is
as important as reading and writing.
So when they first come in year seven,
aged eleven, we asked them, "Hey,
we're gonna get you to find your voice."
>>Girl: I believe that
everyone's voice should be heard,
even though they're shy, quiet or loud.
>>Oli: And we're gonna make sure
that by the end of the year,
you can do a five minute speech
on a topic of your passion.
>>Teacher: So your hook should be about
three or four sentences, no longer.
If I was in the audience
and someone read this to me
or said this, would I be hooked by it?
Right, anyone brave enough
to tell me their hook?
>>Rummana: I remember in primary,
I would never say a single word
and when teachers used to pick on me,
and I used to sit there thinking, "Oh,
no, oh, no," because I was
too scared to speak to people.
And now, I feel like I've
changed and I like my new self.
>>Who here have dreams and goals
they want to achieve in their life?
Yes. We all do.
>>Teacher: Stop there.
That's it.
That's your hook.
>>Coach: Everything we do
here is about giving a speech,
but there is a behind the scene Oracy
framework you're really referring
back to.
>>Rummana: The full project
was our cognitive,
physical, linguistic and emotional.
Now I know what type of things I need in
order for my speaking to be successful.
>>Matilda: It's a lot to
keep in mind at first,
but we're practicing it all the
time in every lesson we're in.
And by the time you get to year
nine, it's almost instinctive.
>>Director: The familiarity with
the framework and making sure
that everybody recognizes what goes
into good Oracy has been a
key driver within the school.
And that means that students give
really clear feedback and critique.
>>Girl: Let's not be foolish.
>>Teacher: It teaches them
how to present themselves,
how to use their bodies,
how to use their voices.
>>Girl: We must face
the facts and recognize
that privatization is a
very beneficial thing.
>>Jawad: You're standing, like, in
the same spot for the whole speech.
You should, like, start walking around.
>>Teacher: It's because
physical Oracy strands...
In year nine, the theme
has been politics.
We wanted to make it like a quite a
formal debate, so you'd have proposers
and opposers on each side,
and then you'd have a chair.
>>Oli: We thought the key thing
was to get them to discuss
and debate with each other.
>>Students: I pull it to you.
>>Teacher: Much better.
>>Oli: You actually don't know how
good your Oracy is until you're put
into a different context and are
then asked to do something with it.
>>As with every project,
we've invited some experts
who are gonna judge the
quality of the talk.
Your job today is to see if you
are persuaded by the arguments,
'cause you'll get an
opportunity to vote.
>>Woman: I'd just like to say huge
good luck and let the best group win.
>>Jawad: Just because it was the
first debate I've, like, truly done,
my nerves were getting the
better of my confidence.
Judge: Good morning, everyone.
The proposition is all London
transport should be privatized.
>>Matilda: So, I would like
to start my argument by saying
that Britain has a reputation of
clinging to relics of the past
that should have been discarded long
ago, a tradition of nationalization
that should have been
replaced by privatization.
We want to be able to be on time
to school, to be on time to work.
This is what we value and
we shouldn't mind having
to pay a tiny bit more for it.
>>Students: [applause]
>>Jawad: If we stick with the
government-funded privatizing transport,
we will only delay the
improvement and health
of London and especially its people.
As we all know, three lines have failed.
If we privatize transport,
then it's out of our control.
Isn't this country a democracy?
>>Students: [applause]
>>Matilda: Jawad, why are
you so afraid of this change?
It's clear to see that
TFL isn't working.
We are having strikes more and more
regularly, prices are just going up
and up and it's getting
less and less efficient...
>>What writing speeches has helped
me with is definitely confidence.
I've been able to perform my
speech in front of a big crowd.
All that practice really does
pay off, and it's a skill
that we can transfer to
the rest of our life.
>>Judge: Reward unto all of you.
>>All: [applause]
>>Oli: Oracy gives children
the opportunity
to gain their confidence
and find their voice.
>>Girl: We urge to you
to take up this motion.
>>Oli: A silent classroom is a classroom
where there's untapped
voices that aren't heard.
And if we believe in democratic
education, you have to focus on Oracy.
>>Announcer: The winner of our
first debate, Ruwada and Lily.
Give them a round of applause.
>>All: [applause]